Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday! It's Question
Tuesday, the day that I answer real questions
from real Nerdfighters. Let's get right to
it!
I'll be meeting my boyfriend's mother at Christmas
and she only speaks German. How do I make
this less awkward?
Well you should learn a little German. I'm
sure there's some German Nerdfighters in comments
who can help you. But I can start, here's
a good sentence: "Das Schicksal ist ein mieser
Verräter." Here's another one "Ihr Sohn ist
ein guter Küsser."
Can you say anything in Spanish?
Can I? Of course! "Me llamo Juan Verde. Soy
un nerd."
Favorite video game?
Original Super Mario Kart.
Hey John, how are you today? Also, do you
have any book recommendations?
I'm good. I'm a little bit annoyed about the
overall quality of political discourse in
the United States. But yes! I do have book
recommendations. I'm just re-reading Life
on the Mississippi by Mark Twain which is
so good! Also, I just read Toni Morrison's
new novel, and I know it's not her best book
or anything, but I still thought it was great!
Do you have any unpopular opinions about classic
literature?
I kind of stand with W. H. Auden on this one.
"Some books are undeservedly forgotten, none
are undeservedly remembered."
Is there anything you aren't terrified of
that you should be?
No. I don't want to brag, but I sort of specialize
in being terrified.
Do you think everyone should consider taking
a hiatus from social media like you have?
I don't know, but I can say I haven't missed
social media as much as I thought I would.
It had become a really unhealthy place for
me in a lot of ways. For the last, like, 8
years I've been surrounded by a community
online that is incredibly generous and kind
to me, and to my work. And criticism has almost
always been really thoughtful and respectful.
But there's been this small, but persistent
amount of really vicious and hateful stuff
directed at me that I just had found tremendously
hurtful, and it hasn't been good for my mental
health, and... yeah. And while there are definitely
things that I miss about my old internet life,
I find it much easier to write and do other
work without all of that stuff floating around
in my head.
Speaking of writing:
What's your new book about?
I can't say because I don't know which parts
of what I'm writing is going to actually end
up in a book, but I did put a clue for you
in this video! But you won't be able to decode
the clue until after you read the story, so
it's kind of useless I'm sorry.
Did you ever read Henning Mankell?
Yes, of course, Mankell was a great Swedish
crime novelist who sadly died yesterday. I
always admired him, not just for his stories
but also because he made a lot of money and
gave almost all of it away. He once wrote,
"I still have a photo on my wall of the greatest
idol I will ever have, myself at age 8. Because
that's when the forces of the imagination
have the same value as the real world, when
they're an instrument of survival. When my
mother disappeared, and I imagined a mother,
that was me at my best."
What's your signature dish?
You know, there's that, like, small plate
that's for desserts and there's that big plate
that's for dinner, and then there's that medium
sized plate that's sort of all-purpose? I
am a huge fan of this medium plate, my signature
dish.
Would you be interested in becoming the next
manager of Liverpool Football Club?
Oh yeah, I already sent them a resumé. My
qualifications include having taken AFC Wimbledon
from League 2 to the Champions League in FIFA
14, and having an inside track on one of the
world's best youth players, Henry Green.
Is there an animal you'd like to see in the
wild?
I'm pretty into tuatara lately.
How prepared do you feel for your drag race
against Maggie Stiefvater on Friday?
Well I actually have a friend who's a professional
racecar driver, so I consulted with her on
this topic and she said, "John, you really,
you need to be prepared to lose." And so,
in that sense, I guess that I'm very prepared.
Would you rather be a sheep or a goat?
Definitely a sheep. I've always wanted to
be a sheep, because then when people are like
"Hey, where'd you get that sweater?" I could
be like "Oh, I knit it myself, using my own
hair."
What's the most impressive word you use in
casual conversation?
I use the word eschatological a lot, because
there's no shorter word that means the exact
same thing and kind of my default emotional
state is eschatological anxiety.
What's your best advice for travelling with
children?
When possible, don't.
What's the greenest green you've ever seen,
John Green?
This forest in Brazil when it was raining,
and everything was impossibly green, but everything
in a slightly different shade; it was really,
it was like home For Greens.
If you could travel anywhere you wanted and
live there for a year, where would it be?
Honestly, if I could stay anywhere on Earth
for a year right now, it would be this house.
Hey, who's your style icon?
I think you mean Styles icon.
If you could be stuck in the world of any
TV show or movie, what would it be?
Star Trek: The Next Generation. Please let
that happen! Please let that happen! Please
let me open my eyes and be hanging out with
Wesley Crusher. 3, 2, 1! DANGIT!
Hank, I suspect when it comes to that last
question, you and I are in agreement. I will
see you on Friday! Both at NerdCon and on
YouTube.